what's up guys bang bang it is lunch
money time we are coming to you fast
and quick because while everyone is
trying to get rich on wall street we are
just trying to get our lunch money right
duh
i said it wrong but whatever we got to
keep going because we only got eight
minutes here
don't forget that block fight is now the
sponsor of lunch monday
go to blockbuy.com block five dot com
slash pomp
go get an inspiring account where you
can earn up to 8.6 apy
or go sign up for the credit card it's
coming soon
i know what you guys are going to say
which is that this looks like it was
filmed
with a potato because it basically was
okay stripe i got the nice camera i
didn't hook it up whatever let's keep
going stripe has raised the 600 million
dollar
series h funding round that boosts his
valuation to 95
billion next to robin hood the fintech
company remains one of the largest
private unicorns yet to make a highly
anticipated wall street
debut do we think they're going public
any time soon do we think elon who
invested two million dollars in the 20
million
so uh elon and a bunch of other people
invested two million dollars had a 20
million
valuation years ago um i believe
that stripe is undervalued at 95 billion
i think they'll be worth way more of
that in the future they probably are
worth more than that right now
but at the same time i also believe that
this shows
just what the appetite is for digital
finance technologies
bitcoin at a trillion stripe at 95
billion i think bitcoin's undervalued i
think stripes undervalued
the world is going to get disrupted by
these digital technologies so
buckle up that's what's going to happen
i do think that they will go public at
some time i don't think it's in the
short term and the reason is because
they have access to capital why would
they want to be a public company if they
have access to capital private markets
you know who else is undervalued the
profile
it should be a hundred billion dollar
business okay dozens of cities are
offering up to 16
000 in cash incentives home buying
allowances tax credits
and money to our local goods and
services and hopes of enticing pandemic
movers to relocate there
and now there's this directory called
makemymove.com
that helps connect uh remote workers
with such
offers around the country you know i was
actually thinking about this and i
wanted to get your take
you know all these like influencers who
used to travel the world and be
nomadic during a pandemic like what do
they do
what do you do how do you find work i
guess you chan
you change your your background wherever
this is our wall but if we had a
background screen back there
back there then you could change it and
then you'd be like we're in bali and
then you change you're like now we're in
mexico
you change you're like now we're in
nigeria it's amazing
next yeah but i think it's cool
baltimore maryland is um
offering this all right google announced
that it will cut
google play app store fees to 15 on the
first
million dollars a developer makes on
google store per year
starting on july 1st after developers
crossed the 1 million in sales a year
google will charge developers at
standard 30
fee for in-app purchases and downloads
god 30 percent is a lot of percent
but 15 i guess they cut it in half or
something for the first million
my god you're a developer
you got to pay a lot it's all nonsense
there should be a free market they
should allow everyone to compete
and uh if they do that price pressure is
going to go down
do you see my cheekbones all right next
next next next next next next next
okay uh fewer kids are going to college
because they say that it costs too
damn much a growing number of
uh 2b would be graduates are opting out
of college basically the only point to
go to college at this point is either if
you're in a field where you absolutely
need
the uh certification like you want to be
a doctor if you want to be a lawyer or
whatever
uh or two is if you want to go party and
get a social experience other than that
there's absolutely no reason to go to
college they keep
the costs keep rising yet you're staying
at home
why would you not raise prices if you
had a line out the door and every time
you raised prices the line got longer
of course yeah but during a pandemic you
can take all your classes
freaking online the fact that they're
still charging the same amount of money
for the
uh zoom meetings if not more yeah
rather than the in-person ones is
exactly why it's a charade
next okay um speaking of college a
12-year-old prodigy
is off to college elena wicker of
arizona has already completed high
school through at home schooling
she's going to arizona state she plans
to major in astronomical and planetary
sciences and chemistries
chemistry her passion for building
started as an infant with legos
her hope is to land a job at nasa when
she's 16.
i love smart people you know why because
smart people
do smart things they solve problems
they're innovative and
they end up pushing the pace of progress
and innovation this kid
sounds like a genius look at what she
said she said it doesn't matter what
your age or what you're planning to do
go for a dream and then accomplish it
she sounds like a little savage
also the fact that she was homeschooled
and then went off to college at age 12
how wild is that you'd love to see it
next next let's go we got three minutes
left it's ask lunch money time
ask lm in the comments below okay
brian asks do you guys believe that
someday centralized banks like jp morgan
wells fargo and bank of america will
sell cryptos directly to their clients
like robin hood and paypal
yes absolutely that's going to happen in
the next like 18 months
i bet you they're already working on it
they're trying to figure out how can
they be part of the marketplace how can
they be part of it
the big questions are they going to
build the internal capabilities to do
this
or are they going to actually end up
just buying some of these people like
coinbase is somewhat like a bank right
it's an exchange or whatever block fi
somewhat like a bank like do these guys
try to come in and buy it
or do they instead try to just play the
game uh somebody like jp morgan's
probably a little bit more likely to do
it than a goldman sachs he's more of
like a trading and investment bank type
firm
uh but absolutely there's gonna be large
financial institutions that want in on
the game
they ain't gonna let everyone else get
rich while they're just sitting there
moist updates what are you doing 24
he's getting rowdy day 24 uh yesterday
was day 23. my comment is getting
deleted again
too okay uh thanks for the advice i've
been myself in these comments and it's
worked pretty well so far since you
didn't ask a question today i take it i
should ask another
i have two have you all heard of the wim
hof breathing
technique and if so what do you think of
it and pom do you prefer a paper wrap or
a tobacco wrap
moist um what do you think about wim hof
wim hof i don't do it but i do believe
in breathing properly that's why i do
yoga
what does yoga gotta do with breathing
it's all about breathing sounds stupid
yoga sounds like you just keep doing
pretzel work on the floor no problem you
can't even
move your foot that's why it's stupid
because i can't do it if i could do it
then it would be smart but if i can't do
it it's stupid what else
uh yeah i actually believe in the
breathing uh but i do think that you
gotta have like a guide to help you do
it
um and also i believe in cold showers
and in like the the back and forth hot
the cold thing or whatever
uh so i think wim hof's on to something
there and he's just proving that you
have better control of your body than
most people think
uh in terms of a paper wrap or tobacco
wrap do you know what he's referencing
i think so what tell us i don't know
something about smoking
oh you're a genius we're kind of smoking
marijuana you said that [ __ ] like a cop
you look you look like a cop saying that
stuff
damn i think that's what i don't know
for sure
hey man i'm an equal opportunist no
worries no worries all right
a twist moisture tobacco what
moist twist gabriella said
i'm still waiting for for moist to find
me on twitter no no no she said i'd love
to visit italy one day i'm also trying
to learn italian at my own pace
for latin american destinations you guys
should check out el salvador especially
now that the country is going through
such historical changes
on another note i'm still waiting for
boys to find me on twitter i gave you
all the details you needed to find me
moist but i can't do all the work
go back to my comment on the video from
last thursday damn gabriella
gabriella do you like paper or do you
like tobacco raps how about that boys
let's get to the real hard questions
right now here's my question for moist
because i have to get you up on a
meeting and i'm going to be late
moist
if given the choice what flavor
or color gatorade don't mess it up
big dog he has a hot take don't mess
this up what flavor or
color gatorade if you'd mess it up we're
gonna have problems but tobacco wraps
i'll see you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me block flies my second
favorite thing in the world behind
polena
they've got three products they can give
you a us dollar loan
you can earn up to 8.6 interest on an
interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends